now you did the Christmas tree lighting
yesterday yeah and even on your guitar
it said uh it had the f word it said f
racism and they made you cover the f
word
well I even have a funnier story than
that what happened I played at uh the
White House oh a couple years ago or
Clinton yeah for Clinton and I have like
I guess 30 inner city kids singing in
the choir behind me and I'm doing like
you know one of my songs I'm doing pink
houses and this land is your land right
right
and there's all these guys in Rock Band
I mean I can't remember who I was there
it clapped and all these people that's a
huge show yeah and I'm like the last
thing and I walk out
Clinton and his wife are sitting right
there I have all these you know
pre-teenage kids behind me and I have
that guitar on I've had that guitar for
like 30 years with that racism on it
yeah I walk out and as I'm walking out I
look down it's on national TV and [ __ ]
and I walk down and I start playing
right yeah and Mrs Clinton is like
wigging out she's going
back and it's on television because it's
the f word yeah yeah and have all those
kids behind me too good image and by the
time I realized it had happened it was
too damn late after the things over
Clinton asked me to come up to the house
so Elaine and I went up to their house
and and an aide comes up and says well
we have the phones are ringing off the
wall about this F word and melon Camp
what do you want me to tell them and the
president goes tell them that misread it